you know i think the the big syndrome
among most democrats if you want to give
them the benefit of the doubt is that
they are a big heart small brain
and so they they think with their heart
and they just want to help people don't
you just want to help people but they
don't think through the consequences of
this it's sort of like unemployment we
just want to help people so why don't we
double the unemployment but what it does
is it leads to people staying out of
work longer
and in the end when they decide to go
back in the workforce people are like
well you've only been out of work 10
weeks but you've been out of work a
whole year because the the benefits were
good you know what i'd rather have the
guy who's only been out of work 10 weeks
he seems hungrier to me and so you
create a whole class an underclass of
people who are unemployable and no
longer part of the workforce and that
wasn't good for them work is good for
the soul good for the heart i mean it's
good for the person and once you get
them out of the workforce you've done a
disservice to that to them and you make
them sort of a dependent on the
democratic largesse and then they become
a solid democrat voter because they no
longer work or pay taxes
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
one of the last sane men in washington
d.c as well as dr fauci's worst
nightmare senator rand paul welcome back
to the reuben report
glad to be with you dave
senator i have a short list here of
people that are sane in washington dc
you're at the top of the list and then i
put abraham lincoln george washington
and ted cruz um you know you got any any
other company in that town two of those
three are no longer here dave i mean i
know this is a new class but lincoln and
washington no longer here but it is a
small i felt i had to pad the list a
little you know it's a small group
yeah i mean how does that make you feel
on a day-to-day basis dealing with some
of the nonsense that we're going to
spend these 20 minutes talking about
that it seems that every
thing that a good decent libertarian has
warned about for a long time just seems
to be ushering in every second we wake
up and another infringement on this or
that is here
but you know i think politicians would
be surprised i go home and people come
up to me and they thank me for standing
up to these people
um and i think that a lot of people
think if they stand up they'll get in
trouble with their constituents i think
it's the opposite people at home are
proud of the fact that i'll stand up
when nobody else will and that i'm
saying things that they're thinking at
home but nobody in washington seems to
be defending them on and it's amazing
how many people are speaking out one of
the things i've been impressed with is i
don't know a lot of nba players but i
talked to jonathan isaacs the other day
i've seen his video his interview
smart young man makes a measured
response says that he wants to make his
own medical decisions as i do
you know having had the disease based on
the on the on the literature based on
the scientific data i've even said i
might get vaccinated someday if the data
looks like it indicates that i need to
be
but the thing is is we have millions of
americans and nobody's representing them
up here they're sort of like just
blindly follow blindly do as you're told
and that's not the american way the
american way is actually to question
authority to debate to kabits to do you
you know whatever it is to try to get at
the truth but we figure out the truth
individually not as a collective
yeah i shared a clip this morning of
astrophysicist carl sagan who's long
gone but he was talking about how
healthy skepticism is the one thing that
guards us from authoritarianism and if
you were to say that now you know you're
basically considered far right but with
everything you said in mind you had a
rather extraordinary exchange with
health and homeland secretary javier
becerra so we're going to throw to about
a minute of that mr basara are you
familiar with an israeli study that had
2.5 million patients
and found that the vaccinated group was
actually seven times more likely to get
infected with covid than the people who
had gotten coveted naturally
senator i have to get back to you on
that one i'm not familiar with that
study well you think you might want to
be if you're going to travel the country
insulting the uh millions of americans
including nba star jonathan isaac who
have had coven recovered look at a study
with 2.5 million people and say well you
know what it looks like my immunity is
as good as a vaccine or not and in a
free country maybe ought to be able to
make that decision instead you've chosen
to travel a country calling people like
jonathan isaac and others myself
included flat earthers we find that very
insulting goes against the science are
you a doctor or a medical doctor
i've worked over 30 years on health
sciences you're not a medical doctor do
you have a science degree
and yet you travel the country calling
people flat earthers who have had coven
looked at studies of millions of people
and made their own personal decision
that their immunity they naturally
acquired is sufficient but you presume
somehow to tell over a hundred million
americans who have survived coveted
that we have no right to determine our
own medical care you alone are on high
and you've made these decisions a lawyer
with no scientific background no medical
degree
this is an arrogance coupled with an
authoritarianism that is unseemly and
un-american
you sir the one ignoring the science
the vast preponderance of scientific
studies
dozens and dozens show robust
long-lasting immunity after coven
infection
even the cdc does not recommend measles
vaccine if you have measles immunity
the same was true for smallpox
but you ignore history and science to
shame the flat earthers as you call them
you should be ashamed of yourself and
apologize to the american people for
being dishonest about naturally acquired
immunity
you want more people to choose
vaccination so do i
you want to lessen vaccine hesitancy so
do i you want to have that happen quit
lying to people about naturally acquired
immunity quit lording it over people
acting as if these people are deplorable
and unwashed try persuasion instead of
government cudgels
try humility instead of arrogance
try freedom instead of coercion but most
of all try understanding that there's no
more basic medical right than deciding
what we inject into our bodies
today after hearing that millions of
people in a study
prove
show without a doubt that there's a
great deal of immunity from getting it
naturally do you want to apologize to
the 100 million americans who suffered
through covid survived have immunity and
yet you want to hold them down and
vaccinate them do you want to apologize
for calling those people flat earthers
senator i appreciate your question and
appreciate that everyone has their
opinion we follow the facts and the
science at hhs we use the
expertise of the medical professionals
the scientists at hhs to make decisions
uh it's a team effort and we rely on
what is on the ground showing us results
except for the dozens and dozens of
studies in fact most if not all of the
studies show robust immunity from
getting the disease naturally the cdc
says if you've had measles and have
immunity you don't have to be vaccinated
the same was true of smallpox you're
selectively doing this because you want
us to submit to your will you have no
scientific background no scientific
degrees and yet you aren't really
concerned about 100 million americans
who had the disease you just want to
tell us do as you're told that's what
you're telling us you want to mandate
this on all of us you're going to tell
us if i have 100 employees you're going
to put me out of business with a 700 000
fine if i don't obey what you think is a
science don't you understand that it's
presumptuous for you to be in charge of
all the science have you ever heard of a
second opinion i can't go to my doctor
and ask my doctor's opinion i mean this
is is incredibly arrogant combined with
this
authoritarian nature that you think well
we'll just tell all of america to do
what i say and they better or will find
them or put them in jail or not them go
to school or not let them travel
the science is against you on this the
science is clear naturally acquired
immunity is as good as a vaccine the
israel study actually showing it better
this isn't an argument against the
vaccine but it's an argument for letting
people make a decision who already have
immunity
you seem pretty common measured there do
you think any of this gets through to
these people
well you know the arrogance he came to
my home state and
proudly proclaimed that anybody who
didn't agree with him on vaccine policy
was a flat earther and frankly i think
they're the flat earthers they're the
ones not paying attention to science in
fact if you are directing science for
the country or directing policy in that
area for science and you say that
science is settled you're clearly not a
scientist because the science is never
settled in any field in fact that's how
we get to the truth scientists like
everybody else argue back and forth you
know on the data they produce another
experiment specifically to disprove
another scientist or to prove their
point and then other scientists come
back and forth and the truth is
determined by that process of
argumentation it used to be that
journalism was somewhat that way too
that we argued back and forth but now
there's there's no real argumentation
because if you state an opinion that
someone disagrees with on the left they
don't want your opinion to be heard they
want you to be nullified and send into a
dark corner and never seen again and
that's the opposite of people who
actually are skeptical and want to find
the truth
so when you talk to them about
monoclonal antibodies or that you've had
covid whatever it might be and we see
these hearings and they just sort of
don't respond or or there's just no oh
we should look into that further is is
anything happening after the hearings
other than a nice viral moment i mean is
anyone looking again at the data and
going boy you know it is it is a year
and a half after two weeks to flatten
the curve maybe we did do something
wrong here
people are watching at home the same way
people are watching your podcast now
they're not watching the nightly news on
cnn but i'll give you an example i
called up a supporter in tennessee today
and he says he has 175 employees he said
after he heard about what i was saying
on the monoclonal antibodies they have a
weekly meeting with their employees
where they talk to them about health
strategies they talked about monoclonal
antibodies and what it takes to be an
advocate for your family to get
treatment
one of a prominent republican in
kentucky i talked to him six months ago
and told him about monoclonal antibodies
he's been fully vaccinated he got covid
was getting sicker no one was offering
it to him i intervened and helped him to
get the monoclonal antibodies not with
one phone call with three phone calls
because there was such resistance from
various parties on this and it took the
follow-up to get that done
not enough people know that there is a
treatment look this is beyond the debate
on vaccinated or unvaccinated both
groups can get sick and are getting sick
but the idea that the government would
own all of this medicine the monoclonal
antibodies and be in charge of
distributing it we've accepted chinese
socialism we may have gotten the virus
from them now we're accepting chinese
socialism in the distribution of the
potential remedy and it's not working
very well
so i mean is that really what this is
all about that they are leading us to
vaccine mandates not even because this
is really about covid but this is the
beginning of some sort of social credit
system where yes you're a good citizen
because you got the vaccine managed oh
and you're also a good citizen because
you didn't speak out about the
government etc etc is that really where
we're headed with this
yeah and even if you imagine that there
is a role for government doctors public
health people prescribing what we should
do or giving us advice they're giving
the wrong advice so if you're 85 years
old your chance of dying from covet is
10 000 times greater than a 10 year old
so should we be mandating vaccines on 10
year olds or suggesting to 85 year olds
that either a booster or a potential new
delta
variant vaccine might be good for you
that's a debatable point if you're 85
years old i would listen to what they're
saying but if you're 10 years old it's
not good advice so like in the united
kingdom they're not pushing the vaccine
on children they are actually taking the
vaccine they have and extending it as a
possible booster for those who are at
risk over age 65. so that's what sane
people would be doing instead fauci
tells you not we don't have enough
people vaccinated so we have to force it
on the children who are by and large not
affected by this disease
so last i saw it the cdc numbers i'm not
making it up people can fact check me
cdc that said that under 18.002
percent of children will die of covid
not two percent point zero zero two yet
here i am in crazy cali where newsom has
now just said uh in effect that all
children five and up they're gonna start
with 12 and up but they're gonna try to
get it down to five and up have to be
vaccinated what would you do if you were
a citizen in california right now if you
were just someone trying to keep their
job make sure that they could get their
kid to school what would you do
move move immediately leave communist
california and get away it is a
beautiful state i love visiting i mean
it would be a great place to live if it
weren't for your government but it's
hard some people can't afford to move
but then again some people can't afford
to live there either because the taxes
and the property taxes and everything
else have have ginned up property so
much um there isn't a great advice for
for people who can't afford to move if
you can't afford to move there are great
places i think even if you're a person
of ordinary means let's say you make 40
or 50 000 a year which i think is a
person of ordinary means
think how much further your money would
go in texas where they don't take taxes
out of it where property is less and
apartments are less that's why people
are moving by the tens of thousands
texas and florida have no state income
tax so there's a great deal of mass
migration going on but the bottom line
is people have to decide whether they
want freedom or coercion and in
california they're choosing democrats
but the democrats are going to tell you
what to do in your economic life but now
they're willing to tell you what to do
in your personal medical decisions as
well i can't imagine wanting to live
under that kind of rule
how worried are you that eventually as
we split more and more and i sense that
is where this is going and good people
are just going to leave you know if you
care about freedom you're just going to
leave these states how worried are you
that in a place like kentucky or some of
the other places you mentioned texas
florida that eventually the federal
system will still just keep encroaching
on them and just say we don't care about
states rights because clearly they don't
care about any of our norms first
amendment fourth amendment etc
it is a big concern because we're
federalizing all of this and now that
you have biden administration many of
the folks from california with bad ideas
like becerra are from california are now
in the administration so yeah we don't
want california bringing their policy to
washington d.c nor do we want them in
kentucky and this is a real problem but
it's a big battle and it's really a
battle between collectivism and
individualism people need to realize
that the collectivists think that you
are too stupid to make your own
decisions so experts in each field need
to make these decisions for you
and that your individual rights don't
matter and the classic example of this
is dr fauci in 2012 he said that yes
this gain of function is great research
and we need to do it we might get a leak
and there could even be a scientist who
starts a pandemic but it'd be worth it
the only way it's worth it is if you
discount four million individual lives
that have died if this came from the lab
in wuhan which a lot of evidence points
towards it coming from that lab
four million maybe i think it's closer
to five million we're approaching five
million people have died from this but
if you're a collectivist you think well
the greater good of research that has
accumulated from this in my
estimal opinion because my opinion is so
much better than everybody else and i'm
the scientist that's the expert at the
top
i think really the research is more
important than the individual deaths but
that he's judging the collective to be
more important than the individual and
that's what it leads to that's why mao
would say what is 45 million deaths you
know from famine when the greater good
of socialism has come about this is what
socialism and collectivism breeds
is that worship of the expert class also
sort of the way they figured out a
perfect system here meaning when when
the numbers go down they say oh it's
because we've still got everybody in
masks and we've still kept people at
home and they're vaccinated etc etc but
then when numbers go up they go oh it's
just because not enough people are
listening to us so they've created this
perfect system where no matter how much
logic and reason you drop right now
you're still the bad guy
there's a lot of studies looking at the
correlation between mandates and the
incidence of the disease it turns out
that they are not proportional at all
there is no evidence that when a mandate
is instituted either a mask or stay six
feet away from people or wear garlic
around your neck any of these things
that they ask you to do they don't seem
to have any correlation with the
reduction in incidents in fact as the
the mandates were coming on in some
cases like in last january the incidence
was still going through the roof now a
month later after millions of people are
killed off the curve comes down but in
all likelihood it has more to do with
immunity but if you want to see the true
dishonesty of these people look at the
interview on cnn where dr fauci's
finally asked a question about natural
immunity he looks at the camera he looks
at the interviewer and he says
well gosh that you're right that should
be something we might want to look into
really the nation's leading expert on
infectious disease and immunology thinks
that after a year and a half and four
million people dying we might want to
look at that he knows very well the
answer you put him on a lie detector
test and you ask him is there naturally
cloud immunity acquired immunity from
covid he'll absolutely tell you yes he's
actually said it in interviews he wants
to de-emphasize it because he thinks the
collective will do better if they just
blindly accept the vaccine
if you ask him is there a chance there
might be more side effects if you've
already had covet and you're a 15 year
old male is there maybe more of an
incidence of myocarditis his real answer
is he doesn't care about one 15 year old
male he cares about all 15 year old
males so he cares about the collective
he doesn't care about your kid which is
not what most parents want when they go
to the doctor a doctor who says well
most 15 year olds will be fine yours
might die but you know what's one kid
when we can when we save the rest of
them
right and we're also hearing all sorts
of stuff from the cdc wilinsky the other
day was saying this thing about you know
women who are pregnant should get the
vaccine and they sh and don't worry
about breastfeeding any of these things
the implication being oh we've studied
this for a couple years and it'll be
okay but that's simply impossible at
this point right
i think that giving out advice is not a
bad idea so i have a sister who's an ob
gyn and she did tell me that they have a
29
year old pregnant mom in their hospital
who died just recently with coven so we
we shouldn't say that it can't happen
and the judgment should be the
individual and they have to do it so for
example you'll meet young moms in the
first trimester who won't drink a diet
coke because they are worried about the
development of their child in the first
three months that might be rational or
irrational but it's their child and
their choice it might be the same way
with the vaccine they might weigh that
decision and they might say well i might
do it in the second trimester i might do
it in the third trimester or they might
say for either religious reasons or
medical reasons i don't want to in a
free society each individual makes their
decision so i wouldn't tell people not
to get vaccinated or to be so afraid of
it that if you're pregnant not to do it
there are some unknowns i would say
investigate it listen to your doctor
talk to your doctor read about the fact
that some pregnant women have died in
their 30s and in their 20s but by the
thing is is
in a free society no one individual
makes these decisions and it's never
right for one individual to make it
because what if that individual's wrong
that means 330 million people when
faulty is wrong 330 million people are
subject to that if your local doctor is
wrong get another doctor get another
opinion try to figure out the truth of
this but we're going in the wrong
direction so rapidly the question is
will we ever get our freedoms back after
this is all done
yeah it's just so extraordinary i mean
the basic idea of the united states is
individual rights and as you're saying
it's like we're just throwing them out
so let's spend the remaining time doing
some basic math here because i've been
told over the last week time and time
again by the president of the united
states and many of the people in his
administration
that 3.5 trillion dollars actually
equals zero
i tried to put it on my calculator it
doesn't have enough digits can you help
me with that math
i think most people are smart enough to
say that there's nothing in life that's
free this is a bait in switch this is
the democrat saying you're going to get
free college you're going to get free
daycare you're going to get a free cell
phone heck we might even throw in a free
car you know there's going to be a lot
of free stuff but people know
innately they know that that's not true
so when when biden says it's not going
to cost anything
one of the ways they do the trickery of
the math to try to make it seem as if
it's not costing anything or costing
that much is they're going to say oh the
bill will only include two years of free
college and does that mean that at the
end of two years there's no more free
college no at the end of the two years
the only way you get for free college is
everybody in congress will have to get
together and get rid of free college
what's hard to get rid of free stuff
once people get free stuff they think
they like it but in the end we're all
going to pay for this either through
more taxation or more inflation and what
happens to inflation is it's an
insidious tax and it affects the working
class and the retired pension folks that
have fixed incomes more than the rest of
us and it's why a decade later if you
make thirty five thousand dollars a year
and a decade later you make thirty eight
thousand dollars a year like how come
i'm not a new richer it's because now
your thirty eight thousand dollars buys
33 000 worth of goods because of
inflation and so this is the real trick
but it's a bait and switch and it's an
intentional thing the democrats are
wanting to buy your vote with free stuff
they give you free stuff but they don't
tell you the honest truth that your
money will buy less each year and that
in the end you won't be any better off
what do you think biden believes in his
heart of hearts i mean i can't imagine
that he actually thinks that taxing 3.5
trillion dollars of the bad guys that he
keeps saying don't pay their fair share
is actually nothing and it won't add to
the debt and it won't cause inflation
and everything else but you think it's
just like the train has just gone here
and he's just going in on all of it
you know i think the the big syndrome
among most democrats if you want to give
them the benefit of doubt is that they
are big heart small brain
and so they they think with their heart
and they just want to help people don't
you just want to help people but they
don't think through the consequences of
this it's sort of like unemployment we
just want to help people so why don't we
double the unemployment but what it does
is it leads to people staying out of
work longer
and in the end when they decide to go
back in the workforce people are like
well you've only been out of work 10
weeks but you've been out of work a
whole year because the the benefits were
good you know what i'd rather have the
guy who's only been out of work 10 weeks
he seems hungrier to me and so you
create a whole class an underclass of
people who are unemployable and no
longer part of the workforce and that
wasn't good for them work is good for
the soul good for the heart i mean it's
good for the person and once you get
them out of the workforce you've done a
disservice to that to them and you make
them sort of a dependent on the
democratic largesse and then they become
a solid democrat voter because they no
longer work or pay taxes
we've developed a society of workers and
non-workers most of the workers are
voting for less government less taxes
most of the non-workers are if they vote
or voting for more government and more
more welfare
so what do we do about this debt ceiling
situation i mean basically everyone
watching this knows if you got a two
thousand dollar limit on your credit
card and you hit it your next purchase
isn't going to go through you can't just
tell the bank oh no no no now i want
five now i want 10. now i want 20. but
that's how the government operates
democrats want to bust the budget with
these enormous bills they need to vote
to raise the debt ceiling it can be done
they can do it through the same way
they're going to raise the spending and
taxes on us through budget
reconciliation they can raise the debt
ceiling but here's the thing there's all
this sturm and drang about oh no what
are we going to do the debt ceiling we
bring in probably i don't know we bring
in about 3.8 uh trillion dollars over
100 billion dollars a month a couple
hundred billion dollars a month we bring
in uh the interest payment's 300 billion
dollars a year
so
you know we got plenty of money i mean
you bring in 3.8 trillion and the
interest payments 300 billion
how come we can't pay the interest so
there's no reason to ever default all
you have to do is prioritize your
interest payments now would mean you
might have to cut some waste and you
might have to cut some spending in
government but if we needed to
in the next year we could actually
balance our budget in the next year and
what we would do is we would spend the
money on interest and we'd probably
spend the money on social security we'd
probably spend the money on medicare and
then a lot of the crap like you know
watching the lizard on a treadmill might
go out watching japanese quail snort
cocaine that might go out studying
panamanian
country frogs are you know have a better
call to get mates than the city frogs
have i mean you might cut some of the
crap out that government spends money on
um which we need to do anyway and we
never do it but uh now we there's the
the whole thing's a charade the the you
know the debt ceiling they will
eventually raise it they can do it on
their own but they want to share the
blame they want us to share the blame
for the debt bomb that's working its way
into our system and i want no part of it
i'm not voting to raise the debt ceiling
because i'm not voting for the spending
man i should be living in kentucky uh i
know you're crunched on time here so i
got one more for you which is that a
whole bunch of my audience and i would
include myself in this we're having
trouble seeing the silver lining right
now that star in the distance vaccine
mandates people losing their job
inflation just the endless lies from the
media big tech censoring people like the
whole thing and you know the california
recall went horribly so you know i've
been depressed about that like what do
you see a star in the distance here do
you see something sort of tangible more
than just human spirit that's what i've
been trying to give people well you know
i would say rather than looking for a
silver lining or saying we have
something good coming
uh if we do nothing we've got the gulag
coming so if you don't want the gulag
fight back but i will say this if you
want a note of optimism capitalism is
incredibly resilient look at the wealth
around you travel our country and see
such extraordinary wealth not a few
people
thousands upon thousands of people doing
well people look in my town i have
people that came from bosnia um you know
10 years ago and that are some of the
most successful people in my town one
gentleman i know owns four restaurants
you bust your ass to run a restaurant
he's worked hard he's earned his way in
america and he's a great american now
that's happening still happening despite
how big government is and despite the
obstacles and despite the threat of
socialism capitalism is amazingly
resilient we're doing amazingly well
there's less poverty in the world
that at any time in world history when
you measure poverty as extreme poverty
less than two dollars a day less than 10
percent of the people live in extreme
poverty now in 1820 almost everybody in
the world lives in extreme poverty so
we've come a long way but we need to
remind people we're here and we made
this incredible success because of
capitalism
senator rand paul i thank you for taking
the time and i thank you for fighting
the good fight in a place that uh it's
not too common
thank you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell